[موسيقى]
اتهمت منظمه هيومان رايتس واتش المعنيه
بحقوق الانسان على مستوى العالم اتهمت
حكومه رئيس الوزراء العراقي نوري المالكي
باعاده العراق الىل الحكم الشمولي لحملته
على المحتجين والتحرش بالمعارضين وتعذيب
المحتجزين حسب ما ذكر تقرير
[موسيقى]
للمنظمه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما مدى وجهه الاتهامات التي
ساقتها منظمه هيومن رايتس واتش ضد حكومه
المالكي وكيف يبدو مستقبل اوضاع حقوق
الانسان في العراق في ظل المعطيات
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
الراهنه قالت منظمه هيومان رايتس واتش
المدافعه عن حقوق الانسان ان نوري المالكي
رئيس وزراء العراق يدفع البلاد نحو العوده
الى الحكم الشمولي واوضحت المنظمه انها
اكتشفت سجونا سريه يمارس فيها التعذيب في
العراق كانت الحكومه العراقيه قد اعلنت في
وقت سابق انها اغلقتها وكانت منظمات دوليه
حقوقيه اخرى انتقدت سجل حقوق الانسان في
العراق الذي قالت انه ما يزال يشهد الكثير
من الانتهاكات في فتره ما بعد صدام
حسين في اليوم العالمي لحقوق الانسان في
ديسمبر 2011 وقف رئيس وزراء العراق نوري
المالكي يخطب قال ان العراق افضل مكان من
حيث احترام حقوق الانسان في المنطقه كلها
وسجون خاليه من الم المقلين السياسيين لكن
عده منظمات حقوقيه تخالفه الراي وتبدو
واثقه مما تقول منظمه هيومن رايتس وش
تتحدث في العراق سجون سريه تحت اشراف مكتب
رئيس الوزراء طالما ادعت الحكومه انها
اغلقتها مثل معسكر الشرف في المنطقه
الخضراء قوات الامن العراقيه تقبض على
الناس خارج اطار القانون من دون محاكمات
ولو توجيه تهم ثم تخفيهم في اماكن سريه
لكن حكومه العراق تنفي الاتهامات عن نفسها
اضافه الى السجون السريه المحتمله
والتعذيب الممارس فيها حديث عن حمله
اعتقالات عشوائيه منذ اكتوبر 2011 في حق
عراقيين في الشمال والجنوب منهم اتباع رجل
الدين الشيعي المثير للجدل محمود الحسني
الصرخي مع اتهامات بقتل متظاهرين ومضايقه
معارضين والتضييق على حريات التعبير الى
حد الاغتيال اذ قتل الصحفي هادي المهدي في
سبتمبر ايلول بعد ان انتقد الفساد الحكومي
تلخص منظمه هيومان رايتس واتش الوضع
الحقوقي في العراق بكون المالك يدفع البلد
نحو حكم شمولي وان بذره دوله بوليسيه تركت
وراء القوات الامريكيه
المنسحبه لكن هل يوجد شيء وراء تقرير
هيومان رايتس واتش عن العراق التقرير
الدوري والاتهامات لحكومه المالك ليست
جديده تماما فقد وجهت المنظمه ما يشبهها
الى نظام الرئيس الراحل صدام حسين قبل
سقوطه بل ان النقد الشديد جاء من احد
حلفاء المالك في فبراير
2012 مقتدى الصدر يصف الرجل بانه ديكتاتور
يريد نسبه كافه الانجازات الى حكومته سمعت
منه للمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من بغداد
الدكتور علي الدباغ المتحدث باسم الحكومه
العراقيه ومن نيويورك جوزيف ستورك نائب
مدير قسم الشرق الاوسط في منظمته هيومان
رايتس واتش ومن لندن محمد الشيخلي مدير
المركز ال الطني للعداله الذي يراقب اوضاع
حقوق الانسان في العراق مرحبا بضيوفي ابدا
معك سيد ستورك في نيويورك ما هي بدايه
الاسس التي بنيتم
عليها هذا التقرير والاتهامات التي تضمنها
ضد حكومه
الملك لقد كنا ندرس موضوع التعذيب في
العراق وكذلك الاعتقال في هذا البلد كذلك
قمنا في الماضي بتوثيق
استخدام السجناء وكذلك مراكز الاعتقال
السريه ونحن لا نزال نهتم بذلك الموضوع في
السنه الماضيه اخبرت اخبرتنا الحكومه
وتحديدا وزير الدفاع بان معسكر الشرف
الموجود في المنطقه الخضراء الذي تسيطر
عليه احدى الكتائب العراقيه انه تم اغلاق
هذا المعسكر لكن قابلنا اناس خلال الاشهر
الماضيه في بغداد وفي اماكن اخرى من البلد
اخبرنا بقصه اخرى عن معسكري الشرف فقد
قمنا بمقابلات مع العديد من الناس بما فيه
معتقلين السابقين ورجال قانون ورجال دوله
وكل ما قالوه لنا هو نفس الشيء قالوا لنا
بان معسكر الشرف لا يزال
يشتغل وان الناس يتم نقلهم الى هذا
المعسكر والى ماكن اخرى يقوم الجي بذلك
وخارج اطار وزاره العداله نحن هنا نتحدث
عن اعداد كبيره من الناس اي اننا نتحدث عن
اعتقال قد يصل الى اعتقال 500
شخص الذين تم اعتقالهم في اكتوبر ونوفمبر
في 2011 تم اعتقالهم فقط لانهم كانوا من
انصار صدام حسين او منن انصار حزبيه البعث
هناك ايضا حمله اعتقال جماعيه في مارس
2012 وذلك
قبل قبل الانتفاضه التي حدثت في بغداد
والمظاهرات هنا هذا بعض بعضهم قال انهم
يعتقلون هؤلاء بشكل
احترازي اي انهم يعتقلون الناس من الشارع
الناس الذين يمكنون ان يقوموا بمظاهرات
تمثلوا ازعاجا للحكومه العراقيه لكن سيد
ستورك على اهميه هذه الوقائع هل يمكن ان
ترقى الى درجه الخطر الذي ينبه اليه
التقرير والذي يقول ان العراق يعود الى
النظام
الشمولي الباد بدا دعوني اكون واضح نحن لم
نقول ذلك في تقريرنا ولم نتحدث ابدا عن ان
العراق يمضي باتجاه ان يكون نظاما شموليا
ما نتحدث عنه هو التعذيب وما نتحدث عنه
والاعتقال الجماعي وقلنا ايضا بان كل شخص
من الاشخاص الذين تحدث اليهم سواء مسؤولين
حكوميين او معتقلين سابقين او رجال
القانون كلهم كانوا يقولون من فضلكم لا
تستخدموا اسمي لا تقولوا متى تحدثتم الي
اوين تحدثتم الي فهم يشعرون بخوف كبير من
امكانيه رده فعل او انتقام من طرف
السلطات في هذا السياق وذلك فعل امر مثار
القلق بالنسبه لنا الكتور علي الدباغ
بوصفك الناطق باسم حكومه نوري المالكي
الموجه اليه كل هذه الاتهامات
نريد منك رد على مسائل محدده مثلا اداره
الحكومه العراقيه لسجن معسكر الشرف في
المنطقه الخضراء والذي كانت قالت انها
اغلقته منذ سنه ولكن يبدو انه ذلك لم يحدث
بالاضافه الى الممارسات التي تجري داخل
هذا المعسكر ضرب المعتقلين صعقهم
بالكهرباء وممارسات اخرى في مناطقه اخرى
من العراق اقليم كردستان العراق والهجمات
المفاجئه التي تقوم بها الشرطه ضد المنازل
والاعتقالات العشوائيه وما الى ذلك ما
حقيقه ما يجري كيف تاخذون هذا
التقرير بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ست ليلى
خلي نركز على نقطه انتم قلتوا انه يتجه
العراق نحو حكم شمولي هذا تقرير الهيومن
رايتس وس ونفت فنتحدث احنا عن قضيه محدده
وهو معسكر الشرف
والقضايا ماكن الاعتزاز الاخرى اللي جنابك
تتفضلي فيها مع كل التقدير
والاحترام تق دكتور دباغ طبعا السيد تماما
تفضل السيد ستورك نفى هذا الجزء من
التقرير اللي عرضته الجزيره الان ويقول
نحن لم نتحدث عن ان العراق اللي الموضوع
الحكم الشمولي يتجه وانما هو تحديدا
تحديدا يقول انه ان الحكومه لا معلش لانه
نقطه مهمه ساتركك تتحدث طبعا وترد يقول ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي يدفع البلاد نحو
العوده الى الحكم الشمولي لم يقل بشكل
مطلق ان العراق عاد الى الحكم الشمولي
ولكن بسبب كل هذه الممارسات العراق بصدد
العوده وكانه بصدد العوده الى الحكم
الشمولي طيب طيب مع التقدير والاحترام لما
تقوم ب منظمه هيومان رايتس وتش من عمل
نبيل في الدفاع عن حقوق السجناء وهو حقيقه
منظمه نكل لها كل التقدير والاحترام
وشخوصه لكن ظللت هذه المنظمه الان بهذه
المره معسكر الشرف مغلق منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه شهور ولا يوجد شيء اسمه معسكر
اعتقال كانت مركز احتجاز تديره وزاره
العدل بحمايه اللواء 56 تتابع لحمايه
المنطقه الخضراء لان في اشخاص كانوا على
درجه عاليه من الاهميه ومجرمين ا سجلت
عليهم جرائم قتل مروعه وبالتالي تم اغلاقه
قبل ثمان شهور وزياده في التاكيد يوم غد
ستكون هناك يعني وكالات انباء وتلفزيونات
وفضائيات ستزور هذا المعسكر الذي تدعي
المنظمه بانه لا يزال فيه تعذيب وصعق و
والالى اخره وقناه الجزيره ايضا مدعوه
مكتبها في بغداد ان يزور هذا المكان لنقدم
بانه فعلا ها المنظمه مع للاسف اخذت
معلوماتها من مصادر ظللتها ولا نتمنى على
المنظمه ان تاخذ تقارير غير موثقه وتنشرها
لانها تضعف بمصداقيه منظمه مره اخرى اقول
نك لها كل التقدير والاحترام ولعملها انا
لا انكر ست ليلى بان هناك افراد يمارسون
احيانا ويخرجون عن السياق العام للذي تمشي
عليه وال تمضي عليه الحكومه العراقيه وهو
منع اي ممارسات تعذيب بحق السجناء وهذا
الام امر نعاني منه لانه ورثنا احنا
مجموعه ساديه تستمرئ القتل والتعذيب من
قبل النظام السابق ولا يزالون و وزاره
الداخليه انهت خدمات 60,000 شخص جزء كان
من عندهم يمارس هذا النوع بالانتهاكات
لحقوق الانسان الدوله والحكومه لا تغطي
هؤلاء المجرمين من بعض القوات الامنيه
الذين ينتهكون حقوق الناس وهذا الامر
موجود في دول عديده لكن في هنا في العراق
الان نحن بالتاكيد نقول انه لا يوجد سجين
راي لا يوجد شخص بسبب رايه يعذب وانما
لدينا جرائم ولدينا عمليات ارهاب وقتل
ليست قليله وبالتالي من الطبيعي ان يكون
هناك مجرمون وقتله
واعتقالات وتحقيقات هذا شيء طبيعي لكن
الشيء الغير طبيعي ان تكون هناك اعتقالات
تعذيب يسجل على افراد والحكومه تضرب بيد
القانون على هؤلاء المجرمين الذين ينتهكون
حقوق الانسان لدينا مزاره لحقوق الانسان
ولا توجد في كل دول المنطقه وزاره لحقوق
الانسان تدافع واحيانا تنقد الحكومه وتنقد
الاجهزه الامنيه لممارسات غير صحيحه في
السجون هذا كله موجود بشفافيه احنا الان
نطلق هذا الامر للاعلام ليرى الاعلام
والكاميرات هي تسجل يوم غد ومره اخرى
جزيره مدعوه لان تزور هذا المكان حتى نبين
لمنظمه للمنظمه بانه لا يوجد ا مع نعم سيد
محمد الشيخ لمدير المركز الوطني للعداله
في في لندن استمعت الى تشخيص يعني ايهما
يبدو لك الاقرب الى واقع وحقيقه وضع حقوق
الانسان في العراق
حاليا سيدتي بالتاكيد ان واقع حقوق
الانسان في العراق يشهد انتكاسه خطيره منذ
الولايه الاولى للسيد المالكي لولايه
الثانيه في وزارته الثانيه وقد تابعنا
باهتمام بالغ كل التقارير الدوليه وقد تمت
تدوين وتوثيق كل هذه الانتهاكات بشخوصها
حتى على اعلى المستويات ان هنالك مسؤولين
في وزاره العدل وبرلمانيين ومسؤولين
عراقيين امتنعوا عن ذكر اسمائهم خشيه على
حياتهم عندما كشفوا هذه الحقائق حقيقه كنت
اتمنى ان تتحلى الحكومه العراقيه ولو لمره
واحده باخلاق الفرسان وتقر بهذه
الانتهاكات حتى نشخص هذه الانتهاكات ونوجد
العلاجات اللازمه لها ولكن انا ادعو السيد
علي الدباغ بكل امانه ان يزور معسكر الشرف
وان يزور سجن خمس نجوم وهو موقع داخل
منطقه وهو ايضا مكان احتجاز سري وانا
ادعوه ايضا الى زياره سجن الامن العامه في
منطقه البلديات الذي تديره قوات مكافحه
الارهاب والذي تمارس بحق المعتقلين فيه
شتى انواع التعذيب طيب الدكتور علي الدباغ
يقول لك انه السجن اغلق لا تصدق انه اغلق
فعلا
اولا الادله التي وردت بتقرير هيومين رايس
وش من اشخاص كانوا في هذا المعتقل منذ
فترات قريبه اي بعد ان اعلنت الحكومه
العراقيه انها قد اغلقت هذا المعتقل
واعطيكم دليل انه قبل فتره ثلاثه اشهر
اعتقلت القوات الامنيه العراقيه اللواء
الركن اياد ع عبد الودود السامرائي رئيس
اركان عمليات الرص اف واودع في هذا السجن
ونقل الى سجن الارهاب في سجن البلديات
ومورس بحقه شتى انواع التعذيب حتى انه قد
اخلع كتفيه
واجلس على اشياء حقيقه بعيده كل البعد عن
الاخلاق الانسانيه والاسلاميه وبعد شهرين
اطلق صراح هذا اللواء الركن و بحجه انه
كان هنالك تشابه اسماء انا اقول للدكتور
علي الدباغ اذا كان شخص بقيمه لواء ركن في
الجيش العراقي يعتقل ويكون هنالك تشابه
اسماء ويطلق صراحه بعد شهرين من التعذيب
وفي اماك في اماكن احتجاز سريه ماذا حال
المواطن العراقي الذي ليس له حول ولا ولا
قوه حقيقه كنت اتمنى ان ان تتحلى الحكومه
العراقيه وتقر بهذه الانتهاكات لانها فعلا
هنالك اساليب للتعذيب ممنهجه تمارسها
الاجهزه الامنيه العراقيه نحن خشيتنا على
سمعه العراق و على المواطن العراقي الذي
تنتهك كرامته الانسانيه في ظل هذه الحكومه
وفي ظل هذه الاجهزه
الامنيه العراقي بشكل عام استاذ محمد
الشيخلي على كل بغض النظر ع ما سقطه هي
رايتس واتش كيف يبدو مستقبل حقوق الانسان
في العراق نناقش ذلك بعد فاصل قصير ارجو
ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
تقرير منظمه هيومن رايتس وش الذي يتهمه
حكومه نوري المالكي باعاده العراق الى
الحكم
الشمولي سيد جوزف ستورك التقرير عدد
الاتهامات ولكنه لم يكتفي بذلك بل قدم
توصيات ايضا اهمها الكشف عن السجناء الكشف
عن اسمائهم الافراج عن كل من لم توجه اليه
تهمه وتشكيل سلطه قضائيه مستقله تحاكم من
وجهت اليهم التهم الى اي مدى تثق هيوم
رايتس وتش في ان تاخذ حكومه نوري المالكي
هذه التوصيات في الاعتبار وبجديه المطلوبه
ومن ثم
تنفذها لقد حولنا
توصيات ذات مصداقيه وسهل وعمليه لو ان
هناك الاراده السياسيه الان كل الحكومات
سواء تعلق الامر بالحكومه العراقيه
والامريكيه والبريطانيه او اي حكومه بلد
اخر فعندما يتم اعتقال الناس فعاده ان
اسماء يتم ذكر اسمائهم ولماذا تم اعتقالهم
واماكن اعتقالهم هذه معلومات اساسيه يجب
ان تكون متاحه لعائلاتها المعتقلين واحبهم
وكذلك الى محاميهم اذا هذه قضايا اساسيه
يجب على كافه الحكومات ان تقدمها وتعملها
فنحن لا نطلب الكثير في هذا السياق وانما
نطلب من الحكومه ان تتماشى وتستجيب
للقانون العراقي وكذلك الاتفاقات الدوليه
التي وقعت عليها وبنفس الشيء نحن ندعو من
اجل تاسيس لجنه قضائيه مستقل ل التحقيق في
موضوع التعذيب نحن لسنا جهازا او وكاله ق
وليست
لدينا الادله التي يمكن ان نقدمها للعداله
لكن اعتقد ان الادله موجوده وكافيه وان
لدينا ما يكفي من الافادات لاطلاق تحقيق
في هذا الموضوع مجددا يجب ان نفصل بين ما
اذا كان هذا الامر يكون نقوم به اي تعيين
هذه اللجنه وما اذا
كانت تؤسس ليس هناك سؤال بشان امكانيه
القيام بها المساله ما اذا كان نور
المالكي وحكومته لديهم الاراده السياسيه
للقيام بذلك وليس ل جواب لك حاليا كافه
المؤشرات ليست مشجعه على الاطلاق ربما
الدكتور علي الدباغي يملك الاجابه فقط
دكتور علي تنويه الى انه ليست
فقط منظمه هيوم رايتس وتش التي رصدت هذه
التجاوزات والانتهاكات كما اكد ذلك السيد
محمد الشيخلي ايضا اطراف من داخل العراق
التي تشير
وكانه حجم الانتهاك اصبح يؤثر في المسار
السياسي العام في العراق والدليل انه
المحافظات التي عبرت عن نيتها في ان تتحول
الى اقاليم تقول انه اهم ما دفع الى ذلك
هو رغبتها وحاجتها الى حمايه نفسيه
ومواطنيها من الشرطه المركزيه التي تهاجم
البيوت وتعتقل الاشخاص على اساس
طائفي يعني مرد الحكومه مره اخرى والى اي
مدى هي واعيه بانه هناك فعلا واقع حقوقي
يجب ان يعالج وبجديه
المطلوبه ا هذا اللي تقوليه طبعا هو خلاف
سياسي في البلد معروف العراق الان تتجاذبه
قوى السياسيه وفيه ازمه سياسيه وليس
الصراع وهذا ياخذ اشكالا احيانا محافظات
تريد تعمل فيدراليات تقول هذا الكلام معلش
بس اقول ان كل هذه الاصوات التي تنقد
الحكومه وتنقد اوضاع حقوق الانسان هذه
علامه صحه في دول اخرى لا يوجد حتى هذا
الصوت وهذا يشكل ردع بالتاكيد لمن لمن
ينتهك حقوق الانسان بس خلينا ك لازم نصير
منصفين حقوق الانسان ليست فقط حقوق المجرم
اللي يقتل البشر وكن حقوق الابرياء حقوق
الناس اللي الان تنتهك حقوقهم كله حقوقهم
في انه يجي شخص ارهابي ويدخل بمجموعه
ويقتلها مادا اسمع صوت من الاخرين يدافعون
عن هؤلاء الضحايا وضحايا الارهاب والناس
اللي تنتهك حرياتهم بسبب انسان مجرم عندما
يتم اعتقاله او احيانا يتجاوز على بعض في
قضايا التحقيق تقوم الدنيا ولا تقعد واتفق
ان القوانين الدوليه تضمن حريه وحقوقها
هذا الشخص اللي حتى المجرم تضمن حقوقها
ويجب ان نحترمها وعلى العراق ان يحترمها
ما ما انا ما اختلف عليها لكن اقول كل
الجهد مركز فقط الدفاع عن فقط الدفاع عن
قتله ومجرمين وارهابيين ولا اكر احيانا
يكون فيه تو توجيه واضحه للمتهمين الذين
اشرت اليهم ومن ثم محاكمتهم هل هو ما يجري
حقيقه في العراق بالتاكيد
سيدتي بالتاكيد هناك سلطه قضائيه مستقله
واضحه في العراق وافضل من اي سلطه قضائيه
في المنطقه وهذه احنا ندعمها ونحاول ان
نفصلها عن اي تدخلات السياسيين سلبا او
ايجابا حتى لانه هي هاي حصنا حصني وح حصن
المسؤول وحصن والرياء الذين يؤخذون ب
جريره هؤلاء دكتور
دباخ لاحظي ست ليلى بالتاكيد لا توجد اي
نيه لدى الحكومه او اجهزتها انه ياخذوا
الابرياء او يعتقلوا بريء هذا الكلام غير
صحيح واذا كان خطا يعتقل بريء وهذا موجود
في كل الدنيا هذا يتابع من قبل اهله من
قبل منظمات مجلس نواب يعني جالس بالمرصاد
للحكومه لاي انتهاك ولا يوجد برلمان في
المنطقه يحاسب الحكومه وينقدها مثل ما
موجود هنا في العراق وبالتالي فليست منظمه
هيومن رايتس وتش او اشخاص قاعدين خارج
العراق هم الذين ينقدون الحكومه هنا مجال
النقد موجود ومتابعه وناس داروا السجون في
ناس يزور السجون يزور المجرمين حتى يزور
المتهمين ويدافع عنهم هناك مجموعات في
العراق تدافع حتى عن
المجرمين الدر لان نعتقد انا بكلمه
النهايه
هذه الممات هي لنا تهنا عي المجو بالدوله
العراقيه و ليست قليله اعترف بانها ليست
قليله نحترمها نقدرها لكن نطلب منهم ان
تكون معلوماتهم دقيقه حتى احنا نستفيد
منها وهم يحتفظوا
بمصداقيته استاذ محمد الشيخلي واختم معك
يعني من منذ تسع
سنوات وعد بد مقراه العراق بفتح مجال
الحريات اشعتها
في البلد لم يتحقق ذلك على ما يبدو الى حد
الان متى يتحقق وما المطلوب حتى لا نكتفي
فقط
بالنقد والاتهام نقدم وصفه للحلول ما هي
ما هي وصفتكم مثلا في مرصد في
لندن حقيقه نحن بحاجه ماسه الى نشر ثقافه
حقوق الانسان المشكله هي ليست بالمواطن
العراقي البريء المشكله هي في الاجهزه
الامنيه رغم الدورات المكثفه التي ادخل
بها الاجهزه الامنيه العراقيه في مجال
حقوق الانسان ولكن للاسف هذا لم يطبق على
اساس الواقع والاستاذ الدبا قد اقر بان
هنالك تركه من النظام السابق سماها
بالساديه اذا لماذا انتم موافقون على
هؤلاء الساديين الذين يخدمون الان في
الاجهزه الامنيه الا تتحملون انتم وزر
هؤلاء وما يقومون به واريد ان اقول اين
الشفافيه في القضاء العراقي وفي لجان
التحقيق لماذا لم نرى اي تقريرا للجنه
تحقيق فيما يتعلق بسجن مطار المثنى الذي
تم كشفه وكان هو سجن سري لماذا لم نرى
تحقيقا بما جرى في سجن الجادريه حقيقه هذه
التبريرات وهذا الاستمرار في الخداع
والتظليل هو ما يؤزم الوضع انا اسال
الحكومه العراقيه لماذا لم تحققي عندما
قتلتي 47 شخص ابرياء في معسكر اشرف في 9
ابر عام 201 ونقل فيه الى سجني الذي للاسف
هو معتقل سري تمارس به شت انواع التعذيب
اين الحكومه العراقيه من كل هذه
الانتهاكات الشفافيه هي
المطلوبه باختصار بالتاكيد نحن بحاجه الى
شفافيه نحن بحاجه الى منظومه قضائيه
مستقله بعيده عن التدخلات السياسيه العراق
الان يعاني من ازمه ازمه ثقه بين المواط
وما بين المنظومه القضائيه العراقيه اشكرك
محمد الشيخ لمدير المركز الوطني للعداله
كنت معنا من لندن واشكر من بغداد الدكتور
علي الدباغ الناطق باسم الحكومه العراقيه
ومن نيويورك جوزيف ستورك نائب مدير قسم
الشرق الاوسط في منظمه هيومان رايتس وتش
وبهذا هذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد تحيه لكم اينما
[موسيقى]
كنتم هذا البرنامج برعايه كفاك شركه قطر
للاضافات البتروليه
[موسيقى]
المحدوده
l